iron you want it but how you gonna get
it
unlike copper and tin it's a little more
complicated
so we're gonna break down how you can
find iron and make some iron gear
in velheim if you find this video useful
make sure to leave a like
and hit the sub button if you haven't
already we really appreciate it
alright let's get to it before you're
ready to start harvesting and using iron
you're going to need to make some
serious strides through the meadows and
black forest biomes
iron is located in the swamp biome which
is home to some pretty tough customers
in velhelm's mid
game the swamps have enemies that wield
poison like blobs
plus tougher combatants such as draggers
who can make quick work of you with
bows if you're not paying attention to
hang in the swamp you're going to want
to invest in bronze armor
once you've defeated the meadows boss
you'll gain hard antler which you can
turn into a pickaxe
use that to mine tin found your water
and
copper found in the black forest which
can then be combined
at a forge to make bronze combined with
leather you can make bronze clothing
that will offer a
lot more protection than the leather and
troll armor you've probably been wearing
you'll also want to invest in bronze
weapons and a fine wood
bow once you've got better gear start
searching for swamps
these dark areas border the ocean and
are marked by
sparse trees and muddy areas that are
tough to traverse
you don't just want any swamp though
you're searching for dungeon structures
in the swamp
called sunken crips you won't be able to
enter these right away
but mark them on your map because
they're your focus when you go hunting
for iron
once you've got bronze armor and a
better bow you're ready to take on your
second target in
valheim the elder which is the black
forest boss
you'll need to locate its altar by
interacting with ruined tablets which
are usually located in
underground barrel chambers or nearby
destroyed stone towers
destroying the elder gets you a swamp
key which you'll need to actually locate
the iron that's hidden in any swamp
area the swamp key can open the
aforementioned
sunken crypts the only places where you
can find iron at this point in the game
you'll also need a key to find and take
down bone mass
the swamp biome boss and the next target
on your hit list
hopefully at this point you've marked
some sunken crypt locations
on your map and you can now put your
swamp key to work
crypts are similar to burial chambers
and that they sometimes contain enemies
in this case draugrs so be careful as
you open doors or
clear pathways try to take out draggers
from a distance if you see them whenever
possible since you don't want to get
stuck in a tight location where it's
tough to escape from trouble
crips are also fairly flooded which can
make it difficult to get around in the
midst of a fight you'll find scrap iron
in two locations within sunken crypts
first in the various chests that are
scattered throughout these dungeons and
second in muddy scrap piles the latter
are big black piles of goo
and sunken crips usually blocking
doorways
you can smash through them with your
pickaxe although you'll find that the
hard antler pickaxe will require
fairly regular repairs as you go the
last step for building iron armor and
weapons is to smelt it as you would
copper and tin you'll need a smelter in
your base to do so
which will likely also require a kiln
which can produce the
coal you need to run the smelter if
you're employing
portals through your adventures you'll
also want to note that metals like scrap
iron
can't be carried through them you'll
have to walk or sail with your iron hall
to bring it back to other locations
because of this it's a good idea to try
and find swamps with several
sunken crypts and build an outpost based
near them
where you can do your iron forging you
can travel through portals with armor
and weapons
but not with metals that haven't been
forged yet so save yourself a lot of
marching or
sailing by making your gear near where
you want to find your iron and using
portals to travel instead
with iron gear you should be strong
enough to take on
bone mass defeating it will earn you the
wishbone which you can use it to find
buried iron outside of sunken crypts
you'll also need it to locate silver the
next metal you'll require
to amplify your gear hopefully these
tips will help you progress further in
your viking journey
if you're somebody brand new to valheim
who stumbled on this video we actually
have a beginner's guide you can go check
out or recommend to a friend you're
trying to get into the game
if there's anything you'd like us to
cover in a future velheim video
let us know in the comments below thanks
for watching
you